hello all you lovely lovelies out there
my name is markiplier and welcome to
kitty powers matchmaker I'm here to give
you the loving of your life with the
love of your life whether you like it or
not so you better love it
or else now don't be fooled this game
was highly requested and everyone that I
asked about it said that it was
absolutely Larry Lewis so we'll find out
welcome kicky my name is Kitty powers
and I'm your new boss thanks why do I
have this job mission is to expand this
sad little branch of my dating agency to
its full potential why is it sad do this
by finding love with many clients
possible so do I have to give them my
love or did I have to find the mother
love okay marki oh man this is this is
really diving into my personal
preferences isn't it pink I like that
why can't I have pink eyes oh okay I
kind of looks like me except with a
mullet blue eyes a close enough that's
why I'm gonna get all I can edit okay
good
oh yeah I got the chiseled features of a
god yeah the chiseled nose of a god
chiseled lips of a god oh this is
looking more like me every day can I
have a mustache please please tell me
how good of a mother what there's no
mustache what is this [ __ ] who a
drag cabaret show that sounds awesome
when I was in Vegas I saw this combo
magic burlesque and comedy show it was
amazing how would I know I'm not the one
looking for dates I'm the one looking
for other people's love I guess
ever your slave Wow well market balls is
here to serve thank you for letting me
service you goddammit milk blue room
looking for a man really
okay gray eyes and black hair big easy
times well perfect
your client I'm hot in pink in my little
black book ah this once I'll show you
the best one click on them to scrutinize
their intimate particular who I'm gonna
scrutinize all over them I'm pretty sure
keep an eye on the restaurant you want
to send them to to rest their days
jamaican jamaican restaurants more
difficult and don't take someone to the
same place one hey oh wait no that's
easy huh no I don't choose that one
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm a little bit
nervous
hey hey green goo be gab that guy out of
mustache where was my mustache bunch a
ball you made me it yeah pleased to meet
you wow it's awkward already someone get
the check
brown eyes and wellness oh love this
nice shade of black woohoo fifty shades
of black is it green hair wow these guys
are connecting on such a deep emotional
level someone tell that one service
summon cold with no meat you are the
most boring date I've ever seen
I'm a vegetarian but they said huh cold
with no meat what kind of loser is why
do I have to do this winter salad it
gets busy she just so happens to be
recently over the e yes you die he
doesn't it
why are you being so weird what do you
have 200 hi how's it going that oh the
love hand no I don't know if I want to
pull the love hand I've I've been
tricked into this situation before it
never turns out well for me
ha OH came right at me
okay sure like my hairstyle
what is that what is that inner ear yeah
it looks great huh okay
what are you thinking about ad Oh funny
shaggy
love it wow they're so mature lime lebra
are star signs they're flipping perfect
this is where they discover their
long-lost brother and sister and the
whole day goes down the drain
wow they look well nice not talking
about to the desired and gross gross I'm
close ss Reza Knickerbocker glory skinny
latte
banana split I've forgotten it already
tits
oh you're telling me I thought it was
that I was pretty sure I knew that they
didn't have tell me that I knew that
they're bunch of dick bags [ __ ] holes
[ __ ] you that's really wonderful I'm
gonna garb that over the gob all over
that who's they it's one person who then
why sure I'm getting used to pulling
that love hand look but lemon blam you
think about clear complete well what do
you think about how pretty my skin is
huh pretty great yeah I know it's
amazing I know you're such a flatterer
for compliments that I only fish for
really hard you like me small do you
like me small moustache I dreamed it
really tiny it's actually my nose hairs
poking out I love
makes you look really hunky keep telling
yourself that I'll call our waiter then
we can go back to my place
with the waiter look like again what
what what huh
all right whatever come on Amina hey
peekaboo
that's when I've forgotten what they'd
look like been looking too longingly
into your eyes
and boobs oh is this Love's first kiss
depending on how much your client likes
their date you now have up to three
options hello oh do you want to become
married hmm
NORs horse narf not horse what does that
mean what kind of British stupid slang
is that okay weird old foreign bonkers
talk is that a load of bollocks southern
call yamimash she's making an insult to
whatever countries from and I'm assume
it's England better not be anywhere else
then I'm a racist I don't think these
guys know how to kiss I did it good for
me marker balls as one hi how's it going
okay now that we're actually playing the
game for ourselves we can see what sort
of hell we can get ourselves into and
hopefully out of or else we die in a
burning fire pit for all eternity and
never see our family or friends ever
again
great let's find some love hi who are
you are you douche names jebediah you're
into conspiracy theories and you're
looking for a man all right cool we can
do that hmm
could you stop grunting in my ear I am
interested in ornamental weapons cosplay
and indie software development that's
actually pretty cool I have a preference
for brown hair and dark brown hair brown
eyes brown brown a brown I like brown
can you locate a suitable love match I
don't know wait conspiracy theorists
that's a job that's a job that's a Jo B
job child oh I thought that's a child
murder it's a child minder I still don't
know what a child minder is also I don't
know signs how would I know which one
goes with which uh green eyes blonde
hair it's kind of close I don't have any
more men Oh
all right okay all right okay whatever
sure yell our listen make him love love
you're gonna love love love love love
with Jamaican hunt of food and stuff I
am Jamaica oh [ __ ] I wasn't looking I
was looking at the camera I'm an idiot
greetings fellow human I would surmise
you're Tyrone yeah you must be jebediah
right most Creole god this guy's a
douche hello okay bye then that's a
little weird
paint douche man chiptunes life captain
youngji rational and logical is she love
a child minder at the Momo
what's the Momo what the heck is a Momo
Oh moment at the moment okay fine
it's all relative and [ __ ] you
so you know so does apparently being a
conspiracy theorist also plays the bill
so I can't really complain or criticize
I have a conspiracy theorist mmm
prima ballerina couldn't you tell is
that is that awesome is that somehow
awesome to you I think we'd better
bounce yeah on the bed yeah baby
oh I find them relatively attractive God
with me now right now at the risk of
appearing desperate yes no I like him
hmm yay what a crappy way to say that
hashtag yeas all around NPI boo boo yeah
I did it I'm an expert matchmaker I'm
the best I did everything right my
romantic ambitions are fulfilled I'm
like totally living I'm alive my heart's
beating I'm breathing my cells are
respirating it's good I'm a
bottom-feeder why am i a bottom-feeder
you look normal
I'm iris I'm a personal assistant I'm
looking for a man all right your makeups
a little [ __ ] up oh hey I'm sure we
can find someone that doesn't appreciate
looks you like microscopes spell books
and making inventories Wow you're boring
great I have a lot of people that like
boring people as long as they're a human
consider yourself to be romantic I
consider you to be scary can you help
find me my soul mate
no you're hopeless lost forever to the
whims of the world you know I recognize
one of your friends I don't have any
friends shut up like blond hair and blue
eyes aren't you in luck she has neither
of those learn to live life likes the
Elder Gods oh we got to match him
remember done date yes love forever and
you're going to a goddamn Jamaican
restaurant Oh Dirk King yeah someone's
gonna be jerking later me on the love
handle hope it goes well probably won't
give up now are you Ian no I'm out of
here
your eyes are lovely children
Shelly can see hey your your brown eyes
oh my god it's so lovely for me to say
Susie it's not just me right that guy
looks weird I'll tug on the love handle
see I told you I'd be doing this making
inventories they're both really boring
oh yeah oh oh I'm boring too
thank you for noticing I like it
Wow they like each other they like each
other okay who the hell are you what the
hell does that mean why does that happen
if that happened to me in real life I'd
be very concerned
what do you are you going adjust your
favorite it what's the [ __ ] tighter
you get naked you're gonna do the naked
man what the [ __ ] happened to you
seriously what the [ __ ] happened I know
what [ __ ] difference was their color
Jesus damn dodge of course it is came
back and completely different person
there's some voodoo [ __ ] going on
here
I'm Virgo what's our thing I'll never go
that's perfectly aligned if you know
what I mean just like other things are
gonna be perfectly aligned later yeah
yeah yeah you didn't pay wait you didn't
pay oh no I really like them and they
really like me my verbosity if you know
what I mean you out of me do you want to
instantly become soul mates
stop looking at my clown makeup like
that I'm not weird yet my darling my
heart is yours also am i changing hair
colors true love lies I found a soul
mate okay thanks human man I did good or
something hi I'm Homer I doubt that
sincerely I'm a janitor I'm looking for
a woman all right sure I can find
something maybe you have no one no one
will ever love you get out thank you yes
sir please come right this way Rudy a
van
you say and you're looking for anything
I like vague vague is exactly what I
want okay Homer he's never gonna find
love for as long as he lives conspiracy
theories tomb raiding CGI effects Wow
you want to be on the next NASA are you
Nicolas Cage I think you might be
Nicolas Cage ha ha ha Nicolas Cage
alright see what we got what do you like
again I wasn't paying attention
I was too much enamored by the fact that
you like Nicolas Cage there you are flip
it up papa do be da be a go on a date I
hope you hate each other I am NOT a good
love I'm not a good love match your
maker wasn't paying attention [ __ ] you
yeah I take that back I'm like the best
matchmaker their error was in the
history of love what is a plonker I
don't know what that means get in there
Nicolas Cage Jesus not me then cuz I'm
not hot with lots of me
haha I'm a van der I'm an alien abductee
whoa okay man driver
ah [ __ ] you huh huh yes no yeah boink
yeah aren't you clever you can do math
mmm that really turns my groin --dl
what's the grind or it's getting late
wanna bang you want a bearing baby I see
you again
hmm all right try that again Homer you
better not be there when I open that
door I swear to go out of Homer if
you're still there I'm going to smack
you upside your frickin head oh hi
why am I still working with you get out
of here Oh screw you that's gone another
day with this lovely lady minions Harry
please tell please my wonderful lady
sounds delicious
I don't know what Stilton is Paul I'm
knackered I'm about to be knackered if
you know what I mean because that found
my soul mate will you go out with me
even though it's kind of what we were
doing but whatever I think I'm in love
with you whoa whoa there whoa there back
up or dad Oh googoo gaga and baby I'll
never venture happily oh I did it I'm an
underling yeah I'm the skeezius skeezer
in the love circuit I skis all over the
place no one will love you all right
someone's gonna love you monsters
live-action role-playing herb-lore Oh
blah blah blah blah blah man yeah
blablabla bla bla no no oh yah oh yah oh
yah oh yah oh yah oh yah oh yah oh yah
oh yah oh yah oh yah oh well a beer or
more Oh bill I've been playing as we to
Long Island listen to a word you said I
stopped listening at haberdasher and
Angus my god I can't believe it
you're gonna love you better love you're
going to Australia baby
ha Oh see mothers Tucker did mom tuck
something she wasn't supposed to tuck
that's a penis that's that's penis
that's penis penis I'm a haberdasher I
love it
it's the Lions come on in the wind of
misfortune to see if your client gets
away with lying the Landsman green
get away with it barrel in agreement
[ __ ] come on
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah [ __ ] you love it I
love it
remember the members of every demand
demand demand demand demand demand
demand demand demand - go go go go go go
go go go go go
now [ __ ] you ah ha ha no no no no I [ __ ]
you
why flatulence really goes down when on
a date
they've got to try and hold it in
predict a following sequence of cards
correctly spare their blushes under nose
I don't want to lower Hey yelled in his
fart oh god do more higher yay oh [ __ ]
oh man everything in order
I just had holding a massive fart baby
massive huh
hahaha
[ __ ] you yes yes build up your
relationship on a foundation of lies and
money it's the best way for true romance
to blossom too bad oh oh I don't want to
think about it yes but the next time big
bag on your knees for love okay you
persuaded me with lies and begging
that's the best way to get into a
relationship these people sure are
desperate oh boy
but that's why I'm here I'm the king of
desperation alligator snake hey I did it
whoo all right looks like Lady Luck is
on my side
who needs lady love when you got mr.
love over here market love market lover
Merc Merc America flutter blur Wow on
the first try baby oh boy oh boy
you're gonna bang they're gonna bang a
route 69 they're gonna fall in love and
then bang do you love each other yet go
out with me I don't want that
can I have some other organ a route to
keep in big big big what have I done
what have I done to disgrace the name of
love how will I live with myself all
right whatever I guess easily so I hope
you enjoyed this game if you did let me
know in the comments below if you want
to see more of it I'm sure that I could
play more of it I could destroy more
people's lives with my
misinterpretations of love what I do
No thank you again everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you
and the next video and then there was a
war and everyone died except for the
Americans of course we beat everyone
into a bloody pulp so that they weren't
even recognizable by their own moms and
we became king of the world